هكذا انها البلدان اللدودان مسار عشر
سنوات من المفاوضات اعوام تغير فيها
الكثير من المفوضين وذكرت خلالها العديد
من الخطوط لتشهد الاشهر الثلاثه الاخيره
احداثا سرعت الترسيم ويحصل لبنان على
الحقول التي اودعها لدى الامم المتحده عام
2011 التي تقع ضمن الخط ثلاثه وعشرين
على 860 كيلو مترا مربعا كانت تعد مساحه
المتنازع عنها خلال الاعوام الماضيه رغم
ان لبنان وبحسب خبراء كان يمكنه التفاوض
على الخط 29 الذي يشمله حقله قريش وهو ما
رفضته اسرائيل رفضا قاطعا ليحصل لبنان على
حقل مع امتيازات اقتصاديه
اسرائيل من الشركه المنقبه تحت زريعه
النقان يتجاوز الخط 23 جنوبا فيما تحصل
اسرائيل على حقل قريش بالكامل
احسن الممكن بالنسبه للبنان يعني بالوضع
البي وضع السياسه حاليا بلبنان بالوضع
الاقتصادي المتدهور ما كان في امل لبنان
يحصل على اكثر مع العلم انه حسب القانون
الدولي الخط 29 ومثل مكان الفريق المفاوض
السابق عم بيفوض مع اسرائيل انونيا بحق له
لبنان بالخط 29 لكن ليه اسباب سياسيه لان
صار فيه كثير تخبيص في هذا القطاع يعني
لبنان كان عشوائي بده يوافق على خط خوف
الحكومه اللبنانيه كانت توافق على خطه خوف
يا اللي هو بعد قلبي كثير من الخط 23 يعني
بيخسرنا خطوف 450 كيلو متر مربع
لما يكون لبناني
ال- اا نصيحه هي
1420 كم مربع يا اللي هي المساحه بين ال
23 والخط 29 اذا تطلقنا انه لبنان حقه
ياخذ 29
بس في عوائق كبيره يعني اسرائيل ما كانت
متجاوبي ابدا ولكن تاخدوا تعطي انه يتفاوض
تتفاوض مع لبنان على الخط 29